reliving the horrors
of auschwitz
the agony etched over his face
and yet despite the pain these holocaust
survivors have returned to this
former death camp to remind the world
where anti-semitism
and racism can lead
[Music]
in front of the gates of auschwitz known
as the
gates of death a commemoration ceremony
in which
delegates from 61 countries are taking
part
and 200 auschwitz survivors each with
their terrible memories of what happened
here
i remember naked women being driven in
trucks
from the barracks to a gas chamber
i can hear them screaming
i can hear it in my subconscious
when i remember those events
elsa baker who's blind was eight when
she arrived at auschwitz
she was one of the 23 000 cinti and roma
people deported here
it is an it's honored for me to to be
here among so many people who have
suffered so greatly
perhaps even much more so than i
and i
i thought it is
i don't know i'm upset
but in spite of the past anti-semitism
is on the rise again in 2020
we hear the same lies the nazis used so
effectively
in their propaganda they said jews have
too much power
jews control the economy in the media
jews control governments
jews control everything we hear this
madness
online in the media and
even within democratic governments
these brave men and women know the cost
of anti-semitism
they can't forget but it already seems
that too many aren't listening
and for more on this story we can speak
to pinchas goldschmidt he is the chief
rabbi of moscow
and president of the european conference
of rabbis mr goldschmidt thank you so
much for joining us here on dw
we were seeing those images of survivors
speaking yesterday saying
it is so important to remember and it
seems that message is more urgent than
ever at least that's what we took away
from those ceremonies yesterday
why is that in order that this suffering
should not be in vain
to give meaning to those and a lot of
people who did not survive
auschwitz the last words which scribbled
on the wall was
never forget and i think that this
is the message to our generation and to
the future
is in order for this not to happen again
we're not allowed to forget are people
listening to that message
i think that the fact that 50 heads of
state
were in jerusalem last week to
commemorate the
50 years the 75 years of the liberation
of auschwitz
the fact that was this great effort in
auschwitz
yesterday speaks for itself speaks
volumes
there will be a time in the future which
our portals will look like looked at
where those survivors will no longer be
around to take part in these ceremonies
how do you carry that message forward
the message is carried forward through
i think that today in europe which is
which is uh almost 500 million citizens
every person every child every school
child
should be one day in his life should go
visit auschwitz should see what can
happen
in the center of
of the world culture in the center of
world civilization
what can happen if things go wrong
if this hate there's intolerance
it can end up in auschwitz what about
the fact that we're seeing at the same
time
as we're remembering auschwitz we're
seeing a rise of in anti-semitism
not only across europe but right here in
germany why is that
there's a lot of political turbulence
the european project is under question
and when things are fine when
there are no economic difficulties so
people don't search to blame
the other today because of such problems
because of the fears experienced by
a large part of the european population
so
we're looking always to blame the other
one the immigrant
the jew so and this is the reason why
anti-semitism reoccurs but
i have to say that a large part of this
resurgence of anti-semitism is because
of the social media the social media is
totally
unedited contents of
of of people who are totally unbalanced
can and influence millions of people
so radicals can influence millions of
people and they are
being given this platform
they don't even have to pay for it and
this is the great danger
and i think the part of the political
turbulence today is
the free ride all those people have on
on the social media mr goschmann you
also
rebuilt the jewish community in russia
after going there in the very
early 90s looking at the jewish
community you have in moscow and also
across russia
but also non-jews how do you teach them
to remember what has happened to carry
that into the future what is the message
that you give them
the message um we give
to our core citizens in all those
countries where
today there is again a jewish community
and i think the revival of the jewish
communities
in eastern europe after the fall of the
war
is has been one of the great miracles of
uh our times and i thank god that i was
able
to do my little part in this the
renaissance of the jewish community
in eastern europe and i think that uh
when we tell the government the fact
that you have today a functioning
jewish community in your country this is
adding to
the beauty of your country
and your place so i think this is a
message which
is being received with a lot of
understanding we'll have to leave it
there pinchas goldschmidt the chief
rabbi of moscow president of the
european conference of rabbis
thank you for joining us here on dw
thank you for having me